[Music]
- toasted cheese please - stormy talk
like you not a demon Tom Sacramento
pressue also a mary wigman
is about passport data store also I
marry women in the East is resonator
they suit each other we pray top portion
or Santo is brother or the pizza [ __ ]
Obito is great you know some taco Ohio
the mission at the mission was the me
show y'all some NAB us to preach most of
the participants also for the first time
have opportunity to take part in a
workshop that is led by artists with
learning disability artists with
learning disabilities are not yet
invited to like teach because it's also
part of the prejudice that are there
that artists with learning disabilities
or people with learning disabilities
they cannot teach or they cannot find
the way and have their own methodology
myself that's I feel enlightened is
everything that it doesn't she unknown
God mentions a known but not about shops
game well if in the Philadelphia by
convention is very long my sis feel tiny
[Music]
except are you stuffing that but I might
mr. shunderson let me just finish
that's what about shops people hopefully
mention some come on here are mighty
kings added presently on dance mentioned
only been no honk
[Music]
defend it but if panting baby fry the
kind of mathematical really tiny ristic
second versus turn our smear almost
missed mousse it isn't as for me when it
music-hall but then what happens very
often in theater and dance that people
who are not excluded reflect on the
exclusion of others for me it's one
possibility but it's not enough for the
European access project for us this was
like coming at a very good time it's
very important it's important for the
artists to be in venues not in excluded
venues but in a venue where you have
artists from all fields and from all
countries and at the same time for me
it's a very important for the audience
to meet people and artists that usually
they would never meet and for us this is
always part of the main program it's not
something like a site we also do the
small project on inclusion but it's
always part of our main programs
[Music]
super important for us artists to share
to share its share I will share our
practices and it all the specially in
warning that we didn't put our just do
this and yeah because share between us
our experience aboard enriching and also
affirming a lot
[Music]
you